this transition i think we're all sort
of experiencing right now which is
distressing and and that causes us to be
triggered and really when the universe
is throwing at us triggers in this maya
matrix of mind that max planck would say
you know
in his own statement he said there is no
matter as such
right and what this really points to is
the notion of a
conscious mind
behind the universe and that's sort of
the far end probably of the thinking of
quantum physics so
in that reality it's not that we get
what we deserve per se
it's maybe we get what we expected
because our belief system actually
informs that reality around us it maybe
it's not a universe as much as it is a
you inverse
project it back it's you on the inside
projected back to you yes all the aspect
because this is your own universe right
it's your own universe
your lens of perception is your own
unique lens of perception and how you
experience that world is going to define
your reality 90 plus of what happens to
us isn't what really happened to us as
you go further in this process and go
down this rabbit hole you'll find more
and more and more synchronicities in the
way that carl jung described
he described the enlightenment process
or what he termed individuation
as the process of increasing
synchronicities
that whether those are they often start
as numbers that might be words
right but you'll you'll see that there's
like this subtle background almost like
a radio frequency where everything and
everyone is almost like on a new script
yeah it's like the same timeline
right
and you know because once you get tapped
into it and maybe most of us and i was
totally unaware of this
collective consciousness
until the last several years and as i
got deeper and deeper into studying and
understanding this and really looking at
the work of people like carl jung who
really just took hermeticism and alchemy
and applied it in the contextual
framework of a scientific mindset
and that's what he did i mean that's his
whole individuation process is that but
he was an alchemist he was very much not
of the same thinking you know he took
maslow's hierarchy of needs
and
added to it another layer not
self-actualization
but self-transcendence
the highest level would be
self-transcendence
or enlightenment
where you realize that
what you deem as the higher self and
your lower self here in this three
dimensional four dimensional experience
are actually not separate at all
maybe this you inverse and how you
perceive the world around you
is just an artifact of your
subconscious mind and you're being
projected back upon all the things that
you deny in yourself and then you see
them in the world around you and they
come back
as reflections until you learn one day
that the things you judged are actually
the things that you continue to attract
yeah and once you finally get that
what we attract is what we judge until
we no longer judge what we attracted
yep the world starts to change so
being the change you see in the world
and going through
a spiritual process is not about
learning how to judge more i don't
believe we came to earth to learn how to
judge i believe we came to earth to
learn how to love
i believe we came to earth to learn how
to accept
which always starts with the south learn
how to accept and
it's an inside job so
our reality is just showing us where we
don't love ourselves exactly
so i want to talk about synchronicities
for a second because
you could mention the quote being about
increasing in
increasing synchronicities
so
is it something that
you find a way to create more of by
being on the path by being in alignment
with your higher self and it's like
or
are we just noticing like do you think
that
you see them saying like are we just
becoming more attuned
to how the universe speaks to us
or do we actually and maybe it's a both
maybe it's not an or it's an end
or do and or do we get on the path and
then we actually do notice them even if
we're not seeking them out we notice
them how do synchronicities work because
i think this is a language that a lot of
people are aware of but they don't quite
understand the roots of it and the
significance or how to or how to
notice them even or how to create them
i think
synchronicities
are
again it's a reflective communication
process
so
i don't know because i wasn't aware of
it i don't know that i had all kinds of
synchronicities 15 years ago
what i do know as i started noticing it
and as i started noticing it i would
start following the threads or the
breadcrumbs
because i followed the bread crumbs then
i would get more and more
synchronicities
so it was almost like the universe
communicating back to me here i was you
know i'm 53. i at 42 years old started
realizing i can communicate
with the universe
and it started out with a one-way
communication
and now it's becoming more of a
two-way street of communication
and i think as that occurs as you get
more of that two-way street you can
start interacting in different ways with
this communication and for me it started
out with mathematics because math and
number is
you know the the universal language yeah
of of of a construct and i fundamentally
believe that you know the geometry has
been all around us all the time but if
you don't stop if you just get stuck in
your day-to-day routine of life you can
easily miss all of these things
but fundamentally i believe that we're
here to find and remember these things
in addition to learning how to transcend
judgment and learning to love and
replace judgment with acceptance
overcome the first level is overcome
fear and separation
right as you break past that and replace
fear with gratitude then you start to
learn how to to non-judge and to observe
rather than judge
and try to look at different
perspectives maybe the way i'm seeing it
is not the only way to see it
and that's when your mind really expands
and then the next step after that is to
realize that maybe the universe is
actually speaking to me maybe there is
some form of destiny maybe i chose it
maybe this is a game i'm living
and and this is exactly what it's
referred to the heroes gamos
right the heroes gamos which doesn't
mean the heroes game it actually means
the alchemical wedding
but it is the that's sort of the the end
result of what the game of life actually
is sure go up to the seventh chakra
which is the the crown chakra and that's
why gender is the seventh
of the seven hermetic principles
it is the re recognition that
you know while it's already described as
polarity gender is a basic aspect of
this universal experience yeah i think
what is everything is gender everything
has a gender
and that's a reference to this part of
your brain called the cave of brahman or
even the wedding hall as it's sometimes
referred to
between the masculine and feminine the
pineal gland and the pituitary gland
and those two things come together
and all of a sudden you can now step
into a new level of consciousness which
is
no longer conscious versus subconscious
but it's actually integration of
subconscious and shadow
and that becomes the super conscious
mind
yeah i was having a conversation with
this
about this with zach bush you know zach
yeah yeah i was just with him at aubry's
conference
okay i was i had dinner with him and we
were getting on this topic of
the masculine feminine and really just
like next like future
future relationship
which
is two things it's one with the self
with the masculine and feminine
and creating that balance and that
synergy and
um
sovereignty
but
then and he says like if you put two
people together
that both have that alignment with
themselves
it takes one couple
to transcend humanity that's right and i
was like
so
please elaborate your thoughts on that i
could not agree more in fact he said the
exact same words
verbatim
at the arcadia conference okay
and and uh it was kind of an interesting
challenge i think he put out to the
crowd everyone's like who's the couple
it's pretty cool but i i really think
highly of of zach i mean he's uh he's a
profound uh thinker also but also a huge
heart
and
what he's referencing is this notion of
the alchemical wedding
the alchemical wedding
in alchemy is the representation really
it's analogous or metaphor of the
masculine feminine which is also
embodied in our own brains
it's the left and right brains now first
of all i don't believe our brain is a
i don't believe that it is a hard drive
storage unit
with ram and rom okay i believe that
it's a radio receiver
yeah and
we can
change the tuning of that radio
hello what's your dog's name
her name is ella i think that she's
scared because there's a storm happening
and they never happen in arizona so i
don't know what kind of turbulence we're
creating right now but uh but it's a big
storm so
she'll just sit there for a moment i
suppose awesome so
so basically this idea of masculine and
feminine is really metaphorical to our
brains which are really processors
like a super super incredible processor
and radio receiver
and and we can tune our heart dial
to the frequency which then determines
what radio stations we're picking up
what frequency are we going to be
picking up so you could have the exact
same circumstance and if you're in a
high frequency mode you're going to see
the positive aspects of that thing
all the beautiful positive aspects
exactly what everyone else might be
going that's horrible what the heck this
is terrible
when you're in a low frequency mode
you're going to see all the negative
aspects of that thing
this is our own conditioning biases and
particularly in today's world where we
all live in an ai echo chamber
we're going into i just wrote a book
called neuro mind
m-i-n-e-d we're all being neural mind
because the greatest or the most
valuable asset in the world now is no
longer oil
it's actually data yeah exactly and and
so as a result i wrote this book with
michael ashley who's a fantastic uh
person as well
and the book goes through this whole
story of how mankind is now being
subjected to this notion and maybe by
our own choice
right again in the context of this
mental matrix
being subjected to this notion of no
longer just selective disclosure but
selective exposure
i can see
now based on your habits and everything
else what things are going to elicit the
types of responses that give you the
most dopamine
so big tech is now the largest drug
dealer in the country
in the world
right they can determine they don't even
have to have fields they don't have to
like plant seeds of marijuana or
anything they can just play with your
own dopamine
and they can create
and foster your own dopamine and by the
way why do they want that dopamine they
want that because the more dopamine you
get the more engagement so
let's make sure that you only go to
websites or let's make sure you only get
exposed
to chat rooms that are aligned to your
way of thinking because as soon as you
hear someone else say something you also
agree with you're like wow i'm right
right and we're all narcissists in a way
look oh yeah we all have a little bit in
us or a lot look how many likes i have
and with that then now they can get us
on these apps longer
because we're like wow we get addicted
to look how many likes this got wow they
like me they agree with me
[Music]
you